when it comes down to it and again I I
say this fully knowing I've got michael
vick coming on and our three have you
ever seen anything like lamar jackson so
i have to tell you this story before i'd
like dive into that we had heard and
when I was in Jax what about this kid in
Orlando and what he was kind of doing so
we drove down to see him play what do
you mean in high school when he was in
high school you just hear like all the
stories about all the kids when you're
at the now it's Jeff yeah so Derrick
Henry was right up the street at you Lee
we drove down to see Lamar play and we
it wasn't it like sat almost to the side
just and he was spectacular then watch
him at Louisville he spectacular there
so you know when I was always hearing
all this stuff like hey this guy should
play receiver like that's all he's ever
played was quarterback his whole life
he's never played anything else you just
have to commit to his skill set and what
Baltimore did this offseason where they
went to Louisville they talked to all
their coaches they figure out what he
did well what he didn't do well and
they've really created a offensive
scheme around that I wasn't surprised
they went to the playoffs last year when
he finally got in what I am surprised is
that his ability to throw the ball when
he scrambles so we always see Russell
Wilson scramble and he'll always looking
downfield
that's what Lamar does now before he
would just take off normally so they've
changed his game a little bit but I've
never seen anything to the fact we're
like they're they dance after every
incompletion every good play they're
having a great time they're smiling you
know he just has this energy about him
that it's weird like I've never seen
like Marlon Humphrey batted a ball down
maybe in the fourth quarter this goes to
his why he's so good and Lamar Jackson
is the first one up there cheering
Humphrey on like talking trash to him
like I can't believe they tried you and
then here comes Mark Ingram here good
like and then all everyone to starts
feeding off that then they you know so
his energy is infectious and the way he
plays they all play for him he's helping
linemen up off the ground I mean he's
throwing blocks when he needs to
he just loves a game of football and
it's great to see an organization really
I'm trying to get the word really just
commit to what he is and say we're not
going
change you to be this pocket passer like
we've seen the Carolina Panthers do the
Cam Newton like no we're gonna make we
this is who you are and we're gonna
continue to build around you I mean John
Harbaugh this year rated the Ravens
caught him sitting down with yes Lamar I
think it was in Cincinnati after his
spinorama and he went for six and he
basically said you know you're gonna
have the kids are gonna be wearing
number eight you're that special and and
I from that I picked up what a little
bit of what you just said they've
embraced they've committed they went in
he was on the hot seat last year John
and he had the ability and the foresight
and the intelligence and the gumption to
basically say I've got my quarterback
that I've won a Super Bowl with right
Ozzie Newsome left this under the tree
before he left
right under the football Christmas tree
and I'm gonna open that present right
now and we're gonna mid-season switch
things up so that embrace what you would
I heard him basically say that to him
was just verbally adding on to the
embrace but on top of it that he's
doesn't have an ego that the coach would
be concerned about feeding by saying him
you know what you're special I thought
that just told so much as to why he is
in a way some some body and some being
essence that we just haven't seen well
last night before the game
the Rams had watts Rams they're one of
their youth organizations that they they
the football youth football organization
that they work with and Lamar goes up at
high fives
every kid down the line now mind this is
when you're warming up and you know some
people take that warm up like I always
try to get into the zone and so I try to
like clear everything out when they were
just as loose as can be
like I mean he has this is his all off
the field stuff like you see him in
videos with his teammates like they're
always smiling everyone's having a good
time when you talk to their coaches all
they say is he's humble he's humble
about it it's not like he's like look at
me look at me he's always trying to put
the attention on someone else and so
they I mean again this is a team that is
young and scary because you know that I
never understood that is like they're
too young to know what they're doing but
I see it now
right like they're just out there having
a great time they're just playing
football like it's in the backyard and
what they do travels well so it's gonna
be exciting to see kind of you know this
next matchup against the Niners how
there's O's and then down the road for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app